c'était jeudi dernier dans le sud du New
hampsez bouillir les derniers litres
d'eau d'érable de sa saison comme la
majorité des 400 autres à sériculteurs
il a déjà terminé sa production de sirop
pour 2023
il a fait 16 degrés Celsius la veille
ces érables ne coulent pratiquement plus
depuis le 27 mars ils ont même déjà des
bourgeons prêts à éclore
[Musique]
la production de sirop reste très bonne
en Nouvelle Angleterre mais l'industrie
s'inquiète de la hausse des températures
à plus long terme les États-Unis
risquent de perdre une bonne partie de
leur sirop d'érable
Joshua étudie l'impact du climat sur la
production oui
le Québec qui produit déjà 74% du sirop
d'érable de la planète dominera encore
plus le marché dans le futur
il prévoit peu de changements dans le
sud de la province où se fait
aujourd'hui le gros de la production
du lac Saint-Jean un de ces lieux
d'études verts et même sa production
doublée des chanceux des malchanceux la
Fédération des producteurs assez
récoltes du Québec admet que le
réchauffement climatique aura un bon
côté pour notre industrie on voit un
déplacement des populations des robes
vers le nord donc des nouvelles superies
où est-ce que c'était pas rentable de
faire du sirop d'érable parce qu'il y a
pas assez d'érable à l'hectare donc
c'est devenu plus rentable c'est une
bonne nouvelle pour l'augmentation de la
production puis une baisse de la
production d'un concurrent direct qui
est le sirop d'érable produit aux
États-Unis autre Laurentides ou taway
bassin Laurent Gaspésie l'anaudière
Mauricie toutes des régions qui
devraient également gagner en importance
et déjà pour bien des producteurs plus
au sud la tendance au réchauffement est
favorable en tout alpha Nord 22000 en
taille qu'on exploite en totalité dans
les basses le rendides Éric Fillion
exploite la myrablière ses affaires vont
bien il a bénéficié d'une production
record de 11800 galons de si Roland
dernier contrairement aux news ces
érable continue de couler ces jours-ci
2023 s'annonce une autre bonne année en
débutant au mois de février là ça fait
vraiment une longue période d'avention
vous êtes toujours à le temps des sucres
une vingtaine de jours mais maintenant
le
il envisage de prendre de l'expansion au
cours des prochaines années on les
hivers plus douces près du point de
congrélation c'est ça qui active les
érables dans le fond que les redous
hivernal c'est bon autant ça peut créer
des opportunités pour la production
acéricole autant vous restez vigilant
pour que les catastrophes naturelles et
les phénomènes concourent le changement
climatique n'est pas des conséquences
vraiment négatives
les essais réagir les phénomènes
météorologiques extrêmes comme la
sécheresse les vents violents
exactement
Eric Fillon a d'ailleurs vécu cet enver
de la médaille et nous en a montré les
conséquences
en 2017 et 2018 une partie de son
érablière a subi une infestation de
chenille appelée la livrée des forêts et
la tuer 800 de Césars c'est les
papillons dans le fond qui sont venus
dans ce secteur-là dans les années
précédentes
se développer dans le fond c'était
vraiment
en quantité
c'était terrible
Eric son est remis mes constates que ce
genre d'événements arrive de plus en
plus souvent les épisodes de météo
extrême fragilise les érables et les
rendent plus vulnérables aux insectes
au nouvel Angleterre ces phénomènes
semblent déjà faire plus de dommages
qu'au Canada de part et d'autre de la
frontière les producteurs restent quand
même positifs
l'industrie du sirop d'érable après tout
se porte toujours très bien en 2023